at this point in the course you've
learned about a few different techniques
for handling images on the web for
instance you can use external files and
just link to them in your HTML or you
can inline images and put all the data
you need for an image right there in
your page you can use raster images like
this picture of the star called Electra
or you can use vector images like this
star from the material design icon set
and then of course you can ASSU images
all together and use font icons like
font awesome and then you CSS techniques
for styling them the funny thing is that
any and all of these techniques can lead
to pretty much the same result on the
page the so-called
right strategy notice the air quotes
there for including an image almost
completely depends on the images place
in your app as a whole for the next few
quizzes I want you to think through some
of the scenarios and decide the best
course of action here's the first
scenario you're developing a mobile app
that displays an ever-changing catalog
of bikes for sale you need an image for
this star right here to indicate which
bikes have just gone on sale within the
last 24 hours
you want to scale the star image with
the rest of the app in order to fit
mobile phones and tablets proportionally
so should you use a vector graphic or a
raster graphic and should you inline the
icon or should you set it source to an
external file think it through and pick
the best answer for both questions